[Music]
in the summer of 1963 a high school
teacher changed the way the world looked
at the Wizard of Oz his name was Henry
Littlefield and he was teaching an
American history class he'd made it to
the late 19th century a time called the
Gilded Age but he was struggling to keep
his class interested in the complex
social and economic issues of the time
then one night while he was reading The
Wonderful Wizard of Oz to his daughters
he had an idea in the 1890s farmers
wanted to add silver to the gold
standard to put more money in
circulation and make it easier for
farmers to borrow in the book Dorothy
walked to the Emerald City
on the yellow brick road in her silver
shoes the movies ruby red slippers
started out as silver silver and gold on
the road to prospered elf frank Baum had
published the book in 1900 at the height
of the Gilded Age and the analogy didn't
seem out of the question no one else had
seen these connections but that didn't
deter Littlefield
he taught his class about the Gilded Age
using the book and soon he and his
students were finding more connections
for instance in the late 1890s the US
had recently recovered from the Civil
War
and integrated vast new territories
bringing an era of prosperity for some
but while industry and finance in the
north and east prospered farmers across
the South and Midwest struggled this led
to the populist movement uniting farmers
and workers against burbon illy by 1896
the movement had grown into the People's
Party and its support of Democrat
William Jennings Bryan put him in reach
of the presidency meanwhile in Oz
claimed a little field Dorothy is a
typical American girl whose hard life in
Kansas is literally turned upside down
by powerful forces outside her control
the munchkins are the common people
oppressed by the Witch of the East banks
and monopolies
the Scarecrow is the farmer considered
naive but actually quite resourceful the
tin woodman is the industrial worker
dehumanized by factory labour and the
Cowardly Lion is William Jennings Bryan
who could be an influential figure if
only he were brave enough to adopt the
populist radical program together they
travel along a golden yellow road
towards a grand City whose rulers power
turns out to be built on illusions
Littlefield published some of these
observations in an essay his claim that
this fantasy was actually a subversive
critique of American capitalism appealed
to many people in the 1960s other
scholars took up the theme and the
proposed analogies and connections
multiplied they suggested that Dorothy's
dog Toto represented the teetotalers of
the prohibition party Oz was clearly the
abbreviation for ounces an important
unit in the silver debate the list goes
on by the 1980s this understanding of
the book was accepted so widely that
several American history textbooks
mentioned it in discussions of late 19th
century politics but is the theory right
l frank Baum's introduction claims the
book is just an innocent children's
story could he has been deliberately
throwing people off the trail and is it
fair to second-guess him so many decades
later there's no definitive answer which
is part of why authorial intent is a
complex tangled fun question to unravel
and some recent scholars have
interpreted the Wonderful Wizard of Oz
in the opposite way as Littlefield they
claim it's a celebration of the new
urban consumer culture historian William
leach argued that the dazzling Emerald
City of Oz was meant to acclimate people
to the shiny new America in the end all
we know for sure is that Baum inspired
by European folk legends had set out to
create one for American children and
whether or not he intended any hidden
meanings its continuing relevance
suggests he succeeded in creating a very
fun
Marilyn can call his own
[Music]